President Trump is lashing out at the
Supreme Court following a pair of
rulings on his financial records the
Supreme Court ruled he has no right as
president to conceal his financial
records from a grand jury but the
justices also decided that House
Democrats cannot see that information
right now at least based on the
arguments they're making currently Paula
Reid is at the White House for us Paula
good morning so what do these decisions
mean for the near future good morning
Tony here the court was making a
significant statement on the limits of
presidential power and now under this
ruling New York prosecutors may finally
be able to obtain the president's
financial records but it's unlikely that
that information is going to be handed
over anytime soon because the
president's attorney has vowed to
continue this fight this is a political
witch-hunt President Trump was indignant
after the Supreme Court ruled that he
cannot block subpoenas from a state
grand jury
just because he's president it's a hoax
just like the Muller investigation was a
hoax the court ruled that the president
can't block the release of his financial
records to a New York grand jury in this
case the information though would only
be made public if someone was charged
and it was used as evidence at trial the
president's lawyers have said they will
continue to litigate the issue in lower
courts the president tweeted several
times that he was being treated unfairly
but his hand-picked justices Neal
Gorsuch and Brett Kavanaugh sided with
the liberal members of the court in a
second ruling Thursday the justices
rejected congressional Democrats efforts
to issue broad subpoenas for years of
the president's financial records this
is a fishing expedition but Democrats
say they'll continue to try to obtain
the documents through the lower courts
we have a path that the Supreme Court
has laid out that we certainly will not
ignore and we will never stop our
oversight in the New York case
prosecutors are seeking the records as
part of an investigation into hush money
payments allegedly paid to former adult
film stars stormy Daniels
who claims she had an affair with the
president before he took office Michael
Cohen the president's former lawyer and
fixer landed a three-year prison
sentence as part of his involvement in
the payments
Koen was released to home confinement
earlier this year over coronavirus
concerns in prisons but he was recently
seen eating dinner out in New York City
potentially violating the terms of his
release he was taken back into custody
Thursday the Bureau of Prisons says
Cohen was taken into custody because he
refused to sign this document obtained
by CBS News that would have limited his
ability to use as social media to talk
to the press and even to write a book
while in custody
Nicole's legal adviser says once he was
actually being cuffed he did agree to
sign the document but he was still taken
into custody Gail yeah I heard
authorities said well it's too late we
gave you the chance all right Paula
thank you very much